[Music]
how do you appropriately bring up the
topic of depression or despair with
someone who you are close to and are
worried about no i wonder about a
question like this pete because
quite often what we want to do is we
want to fix other people and i know
because i feel that impulse myself
and there's a bit of hubris in there
like if danny unknown is over there and
i just want to
to fix something that i perceive to be
wrong with him so i may be
assigning depression or despair to him
and he may be or may not be depressed
and and so we have to be really careful
here because quite often what we're
doing is we're simply
judging and judgment is just a mirror
that reflects our own internal
insecurities
right and so by bringing up the despair
or the depression in danny or podcast
shawn or jordan here
what i might really be saying is i'm
bringing up the my own despair my own
depression and i'm hurling it at them
yes yes yeah that can happen absolutely
and we see
uh in the other what we're
what we can't uh address in ourselves
yes and it's one of the reasons that
so many people when you see these sort
of self-help gurus who go around fixing
everyone and then you learn about some
tremendous scandal in their life right
because they were so busy fixing
everyone else
because that was the easy way to not
have to deal with their own internal
work depression anxiety stress
turmoil yeah because actually the funny
thing is and i think people will
resonate with this is
actually
if you're in a good place yourself and
you've done a lot of work and you're a
calm presence for people and you're not
always talking or whatever and your calm
presence
people will start talking about
their their issues and you become a
mirror of their own disavowed selves so
somebody like you don't need to point
anything out to people
if you are if you're a if you're a calm
and and grinded individual and you lit
really listen
if someone's depressed
they'll start to
they'll start to share it and all you
have to be is a type of mirror for them
now the funny thing is
most depression starts not subjectively
but objectively people think i've talked
to somebody recently about the system
who um
said she wasn't depressed i'm not
depressed and she listed all the reasons
why she wasn't depressed
and
three talkings here i was saying well
here's the funny thing is there's a
depression of not knowing you're
depressed where your depression is not
subjective it's objective it's in the
tapping of your finger it's in that
outburst of anger or it comes out in a
bad back or digestive problems or
whatever it is
the depression has not been
subjectivized so you're always partying
i'm i'm not depressed i'm partying i'm
having a great time i'm always around
people go precisely because if you were
alone for too long you would
subjectively encounter it so the
objective partying is the evidence of
the depression
and so
one of the first steps is to be able to
subjectivize to to be able to look at
your life and go for example i'm always
i party and i'm always with other people
i'm always frantically doing things
maybe i'm depressed and i just don't
know it and then as you
open yourself up to that notion weirdly
the it starts to actually help diminish
the depression as well so if we think of
depression as subjective as i say
sometimes it's objective it's it's in
it's in the world and you have to
subjectivize it but um yeah now what
would you say and i wanted to talk to
you about this we did a private podcast
together
and uh
for patreon and
i wanted to ask you this but i didn't
get around to it but the opposite of
that is like someone like me i don't
like spending much time with people like
i spend probably
90 of my time alone so what does that
say about me from an outside perspective
hold up a mirror for me for a moment
okay well so what what do i think about
you and your what do we think about
someone we don't have to it doesn't have
to be me but i'm happy that's
psychoanalysis but no yeah no i'm all
for the psychoanalyzing here so tell me
about about me someone who doesn't enjoy
the partying in fact like that seems
like a particular kind of dread to me
even going out to meals with most
there's like maybe three dozen people in
the world that i enjoy having a meal
with you're one of them but like there
are just a few people where i i really
cherish and value that time but even
those are in low doses yes and there's
something
draining or even dreadful about spending
too much time with uh with people other
than myself although maybe there's some
dread with spending time with myself as
well yeah well i mean
for me the simplest definition of a of a
symptom
is something that causes you suffering
so if being if partying doesn't cause
you suffering or being alone doesn't
cause you suffering if it if it helps
you
and it's it's in it's enriching then
it's fine so there's like there's no
objective re like there's no objective
answer should i party more should i be
more quiet it's it's almost like
is it is it something that's causing you
suffering in work and love and and freud
used that example he says you know in
work and love
are you struggling and if if someone and
we're all struggling and work and love
to some extent but if um
if it's not
that bad then then it's not unhealthy so
you can be you know alone with yourself
so i'm the same as you i live a very
quiet life and
you know i do i do enjoy socializing but
and minimally so you know and so the
other once every five years
so if ryan were here if he didn't have
his cold and and he were here he's the
sort of opposite of me he
if he were to spend time alone excessive
amounts of time alone there would be a
particular suffering there right and so
as you're saying it's not that one is
good one is
preferable
writ large it's one is preferable at the
individual level like if you if you
couldn't leave the house like if you
literally like you didn't want to do
this anymore you got anxious about even
opening the front door then it's a
symptom then you know then there's
there's an issue but um again it's
looking and going are you afraid of open
space are you afraid of people are you
are you afraid of leaving the house and
and that's different from
really enjoying your space right and
enjoying thinking and enjoying
reflection those are two very different
things and i lack that desire to go out
and spend a lot of time with people i
thought i had it
at one point in time because it was this
sort of mimetic desire i should want to
party like everyone else i should want
to be extremely social i should be in a
job that requires me to spend 60 or 70
hours a week around
tremendous amounts of people right
it's not that those things are wrong
they were just inappropriate for me yeah
well this is part of the reason why i'm
in la i mentioned the other reason
earlier but one of the reasons as well
is
i'm so introverted that if i lived
somewhere quiet i'd probably never leave
the house again so that's the same way
so it's great to have like i don't know
if you're the same i've got a couple of
friends who are really extrovert and i
love it because they even and i get
angry at them sometimes but they know
that i'm not so they draw me out of
myself and then i also grind them
because you know i'm boring enough that
like they you know if they get a two out
of hand at a party i can go and smile
you gotta chill out you know but also
they're the ones who goes pete you
haven't gone out of the house for a
month you have to come for a party and
so maybe maybe if you're a party or you
need to find those quiet friends like us
and if you're quiet like us we need the
odd extrovert so you and ryan is a good
uh mix probably yeah for sure
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free